with us now from Capitol Hill only on
CBS this morning is Republican senator
Tim Scott of South Carolina he was with
Ivanka Trump yesterday to promote
increasing the child tax credit
senator good morning good morning good
to be with you it's good to have you let
me begin with this what are what is the
single most divisive issue with respect
to deductions or whatever it is among
Republicans that might threaten this
passage of this bill well hopefully
there's nothing that will threaten the
passage of this bill however there are a
number of itemized deductions that
people will see a sacred cow so we're
gonna have to go through the process of
understanding and appreciating the
impact that will have on our ability to
lower taxes for the average hard-working
person in the middle class where do you
stand on capping the the deduction for
401 K s in other words should should
wealthy Americans get that deduction
well I spent 20 years in the financial
services industry so I'm a huge fan of
making sure that we preserve the
retirement incentive if you think about
it this way in South Carolina the
average South Carolinian has about 1
years of income in his retirement or her
retirement account that is not good news
we need to make sure that we continue to
encourage retirement savings so that
fewer people are challenged while
they're in there as I used to call it
the third half of their life the part of
their life where they get to enjoy the
benefits of school and work now the New
York Times has described this this tax
reform plan as the glue holding the
party together adding this analogy it's
a bit like having a baby to save a
failing marriage what do you think will
happen if the tax reform plan doesn't
pass and has a Republican Party learned
anything from the failure to repair and
replace Obamacare that they could use in
the tax reform plan to make sure that
they have more success there well a I'm
confident that this time will pass B
what we've learned through our previous
failures is how to get it right the
reality of it is the House the Senate
and the White House we've been talking
for months about tax reform we
not all on the same page - in the
healthcare debate we are on the same
page as a relates to tax reform now
we're gonna have to work out the unique
nuances between each plan but the good
news is we're looking at getting this
done by Thanksgiving so folks will have
a great opportunity to understand what
it is we're doing for them by the time
we get to the holidays how do you've had
two colleagues in the Senate speak out
against President Trump and the mood in
the country but where do you stand on
that and how serious of a division is
there within the Republican Party
well there's one thing that's certain
with the Republican Party that we are we
are not a homogenous group of folks who
all think exactly the same which is good
news for the American people
the tint is big enough for a lot of
diverse opinions within the party at the
same time the focus of the Republican
Party is not on the party it's on the
American people
we have sometimes strong differences on
how we believe we bridge the gap to make
sure that the average person has a
better future than they had a good past
so for us to get there there's going to
be some disagreements I think that's
actually healthy for the party and
frankly healthy for the country as long
as they're for the country do you agree
with the criticism from Senator flake
and from Senator corker well I'm not
gonna get into the criticisms of any
specific senator or individual what I
know is that healthy debate is necessary
for us to challenge some of the highest
and highest priorities of the American
people and the largest issues that loom
large for our country healthy for the
someone from your party to say the
President of the United States is a
danger to democracy that it's a sickness
that's contagious that's healthy wealthy
for our country is for us a debate tax
credits I know that is certainly popular
for news to talk about the differences
in the divide in the party I'm not gonna
jump into that with you guys what I'm
gonna do is focus my attention to my
responsibilities at first to take care
of the American people have to relates
to tax reform and other major issues the
spats between individuals that's not my
priority - nor my objective to get
involved in those stats what is my
objective is a make sure that we are
sincere consistent and clear with the
American people on my priorities for the
America
people senator can you pledge that the
tax reformer tax cut will be
revenue-neutral and won't add to the
debt yeah so there are the answer of
course is yes that if you look at the
impact of lowering the impediments for
economic and dynamic growth you'll have
an opportunity to experience more
economic activity that more economic
activity with meaning people will spend
more money if you give folks 25 more
dollars in their paycheck they're going
to spend $20 that activity is without
question real and with a small increase
in activity we'll see ourselves that
with a stronger more dynamic economy
Senator Scott we thank you for taking
time to join us this morning we really
do appreciate that absolutely thank you
thanks